I
you don't have to choose between doing
what you love and making a good living
being that's what you hope to grow into
as normal in your kid sooner or later
though you reach a certain age where
people stop asking or if they do the
tone of the question becomes ominous
suddenly what are your dreams you can do
anything you want becomes what are you
going to do with your life you better
figure out soon no matter your choice
you'll probably jump into it with
limited information and without a full
understanding either how to get there or
what the landscape will look like when
you finally arrived and the complicate
matters further throughout the next few
years all sorts of things may happen and
change the course of those initial
decisions after initial investigation
into something you thought you'd enjoy
perhaps a college class or an internship
or a first job you might discover that
it's not your thing after all you may
get a degree in something only to
discover that the field you're
interested in has become outdated or you
might start looking for a position only
to find the job market in your proposed
field is particularly crowded or maybe
you start a family and those choices
affect the career options that are
available to you most common of all and
no matter what course of action you take
you may stumble into something
completely different as you go along you
may discover a skill you didn't know you
had a partial you never thought you'd
have the chance to pursue or a new job
opportunity you never expected maybe a
former colleague calls you to offer you
a job at a new company for a part-time
business shift with a friend from
college turns into a real business you
didn't plan for it but all of a sudden
you're doing something you've never
considered before for the most part we
all want to find a career that meets the
same few specific needs what simply here
is what we're looking for something that
makes us happy joy something that's
financially viable money something that
maximizes our unique skills flow there's
more than one path to this ideal world
but without all of these characteristics
being met you won't have a perfect match
it's entirely possible to do something
you love that doesn't pay well it's also
possible to get paid well for something
you dislike or something you just
tolerate plenty of people essentially
forward you compromise putting up with a
bad situation in exchange for a good
paycheck finally it's also important to
enjoy what you do or get paid well for
it or both but to still lack that sense
of all-encompassing flow where the hours
pass like minutes because you're so
completely in the zone of doing
something you're really good at none of
those situations is what you want though
to find the work you're going to do you
need the right combination of joy money
and flow
you